like it must feel incredible after all
this time to finally be able to talk
about Canada's drag race I mean I always
think about it like the way Marvel
actors are not allowed to talk about
anything coming up in those movies it's
like your version of that how does it
feel now to be able to finally talk
about it amazing so good I mean it's
like I've kind of gone through this
before when I was competing on the show
that you we had this whole long waiting
process of where you couldn't say
anything but you knew it was coming and
now it just feels like you can finally
spill your guts a little bit when it's
when it's finally and that feels like
all over again it's no different being a
judge I'm just as excited to be a judge
on the show as I was to be a contestant
so it's been it's been hard to keep
quiet but I'm just so excited that we
got to share this with everybody now
yeah I've gone through it several times
before as well but you know the
non-disclosure agreements and contracts
Isan on Drag Race are airtight so it's
something that I'm a secret that I've
been used to keeping but more so than
being able to talk about it is being
able to show everybody what it is that
we created now that the trailers have
been released into the world it's just
been such a dream to see the response
from from the world at large yes
definitely exciting Carlos I mean it was
definitely hard for me to like keep my
mouth shut those paperwork's helped me a
lot but you know I couldn't wait I
couldn't wait to uh you know let the
world know as well I mean this is a very
inspiring show and you know to be able
to be a part of it and especially with
these awesome right here Brooklyn and
Jeffrey I mean it was you know it was
really you know just really a joy to
work with him be a part of and a
blessing and to work with the Queens I
mean you know it was it's like it's like
living a dream you know so so it was
definitely like like like exciting and
nerve-wracking that I couldn't tell the
world yet so as the judges of season 1
what are you looking for in a season one
winner look what criteria do you need
someone to check off to get that kind of
the three of you being judges I'm sure
you all have your own
versions of that list I'm looking for
somebody with confidence and
professionalism and somebody that's
gonna be able to go out there like a
queen that's gonna go out there and like
really represent in all aspects you know
both professionally personally you know
not be afraid to like you know speak
their truth speak their you know speak
about their experiences both in life
personally and professionally looking
for somebody that's like you know a
go-getter right that's that that's gonna
work hard and that is gonna also take
this opportunity and you know make the
best of it and just like one with it and
not only that would also share with
others as well and inspire others as
well so that's what I'm looking for in a
in in that way no I mean I'm looking for
the obvious charisma uniqueness nerve
and talent that we own but yeah I'm and
I'm just looking for that I always look
for that indescribable indescribable
Janice a qua that thing that makes
somebody a star that unteachable quality
is I like to say that's what I always
look for looking for someone who's a
great representation for the brand um
and some yeah who is just like Stacy
said really a go-getter we want someone
who's a hustler we want someone who's
going to take this and run with it and
really turn this into a life-changing
opportunity for them and represent
Canada and represent Canada's drag race
really well mm-hmm and I'm looking for
somebody who has heart and who was
willing to show their heart and share it
with the world there's something to be
sensitive Souls and somebody who's
willing to tap into their own
authenticity and vulnerability and
that's how the audience falls in love
with you and that's how we as does fall
in love with you the Queen's are some of
the best in Canada promos all look
incredible can you speak to what we'll
be seeing and the different sort of
aesthetics that we'll be seeing the
season different aesthetics oh my god
well we have pageant queens we have
clown queens
we have dancing Queens
we have dancehall queen
[Laughter]
we really do have it all we have a very
wide variety for you we have comedy
Queens I mean there's so much there's so
many different kinds of drag in general
and so many different kinds of drag in
Canada that we have on the show and it's
gonna be really exciting for ever to
kind of see and discover everyone's own
unique personality and their own unique
drag because it all is very quirky and
different Jeff you sat on the judging
panel of drag race a few times now how
did these Queens here in Canada compare
did they exceed your expectations
they blew my mind truly the only
reference for Canadian drag queens that
I had was the one and only Brooklyn
Heights so she set a very very high bar
and my expectations really were up here
and all of these Queens if not match
surpassed my expectations people are
going to be blown away by the level of
talent from coast-to-coast that Canada
has in terms of drag performers and
artists it is it's unbelievable what
these Queens have to offer there's not a
weak link in the bunch yeah you know as
judges you get a front-row seat to just
incredible performances every single
time Stacy was it just the most fun set
to be on what was it like oh my gosh it
was so much fun I mean I would there was
so much laughter so much joy like you
know working with my fellow judges you
know even though the production like the
team everyone and everyone like the
behind it's everyone was just it was a
it was a great time was the most fun
I've had on a job I have to play like
via a lot of laughter there was even
tears too you know like you know there
was a lot of tears as well too like we
were just it was really weird because
it's like we all just met a lot of us we
all clicked it was like this is surreal
because it's you know it's usually not
that case in the entertainment industry
you know there's a lot of decision a lot
of eagles going on right and everyone
it's all about self and looking out for
self but for some reason within you know
within our you know we did this this
this job it was just totally different
everybody was a so like it was like a
family for real like together
like a family so a lot of laughter it
was mad fun mad fun oh my gosh like I
was blown away at times I got a lot of
surprises myself the hell I learned a
lot I thought I'm gonna tell you on the
side Carlos I would tell you like you
know great people at the end of the day
this is still a competition
yeah so when you know when they get
competitive there's got to be drama
right what can you tell us about that
like how much of that are we going to
see I think you'll see a good amount of
drama I mean we don't I don't really
know what's gonna be shown because I'm
definitely the first couple episodes I
was definitely behind that double way
makeup me or like drama
I mean drama comes drama and Shana are a
part of being a drag queen it's a it's
an age-old tradition as you know part of
my so it's all part of the fun and I
mean what is reality what is reality TV
without a little bit of drama like yeah
this is not really as friends race well
Brooklyn did it did it bring back any
sort of memories feel like when you're
watching them compete are you thinking
to yourself you know what you went
through and you're you're trying to give
them that same experience absolutely
honestly like it it I really really felt
for them and I didn't realize how much I
would feel for them sitting there
judging them because I know I I just
remembered what they were feeling what I
was feeling when I was up there and how
hard it was and when you got a bad
critique or you knew you had a bad week
or how wonderful it was when you knew
you had a really great week and that
excitement and how that pride you had in
yourself and so it was really hard but
it made I think it makes me a better
judge because I can really relate to
them on a personal level that way and
they know that that I can relate to them
and but it was really difficult I have
to tell you the first elimination I
cried like after we filmed everything I
just I I started crying like I was like
that was a
harder than I thought it was going to be
because we I think all three of us
judges take this job very seriously and
we know that we are holding these Queens
futures and our hands in a way and that
is not something I take lightly at all
and I know it's not something Geoffrey
or Stacey takes lightly either mm-hmm
the show has been such a big influence
in his Pride Month and in the year 2020
you know drag is important used to be to
drag is an important political statement
that needs to be seen and heard
Geoffrey drag has always been political
and something that we in the queer
community know that fifty-one years ago
during the Stonewall riots that was
incited by drag queens and black and
brown trans women it was the the
epicenter of and the beginning of pride
as we know it today and tried is truly
we as others in the LGBTQ spectrum
demanding equal rights that is what it
comes down to yes it's a celebration of
self it's a celebration of artistry and
of our brothers and sisters and
non-binary siblings but at the end of
the day it's it our our goal is is to
reach the great equalizer to all of us
for all of us to be able to receive and
embody the same human rights that are
granted to our heteronormative
cisgendered Caucasian brothers and
sisters so at the end of the day yes it
is about expanding consciousness and
showing people the spectrum of the LGBTQ
world in a different way but it's about
changing policy and changing how our
leaders see us because once you can peel
back the layers of other humanity and us
as queer people there will be no
question as to whether or not we deserve
equal rights